[Music]
if you don't deserve it news submitted
by invisible camouflage Howard Stern
wants Oh Jay Simpson kicked off Twitter
oh damn if Howard Stern who's all for
mr. shock jock provocative yeah was in
jail Oh Jay yeah a little bit now he's
out got out and then he wrote that book
if I did it no that was before he got in
jail oh he wrote the book before yeah
have you guys heard Dave Chappelle stand
up about the times he's met Oh Jay yes
the three times is fantastic yeah he's
scared over yeah wait didn't he go to
jail for robbery in Las Vegas he stole
his only own merch back that way don't
you ever feel that sometimes I heard
that guy Zimmerman that killed Trayvon
Martin yeah similar idea where after
they're proven innocent by a jury just
their actions are so super sketch
Zimmerman has exhibited similar behavior
not quite the same thing going back to
jail but just very erratic it's if
you're free like aren't you happy like
live your life living with the guilt but
OJ it's like man you are cracking like
you clearly hit yeah you're like trying
to tell everyone yeah same idea was
Zimmerman's again we really feel about
that I don't know yeah so Oh Jay joined
Twitter recently and he's just been
posting photos arming videos of himself
at the golf course enjoying himself and
just having opinions on politics and on
fantasy football stuff no politician
wants them to be endorsed by ojz I
really like this candidacy no have you
seen that SNL sketch about oj going on a
date
no no it's with gal gadot oh it's so
funny so like she doesn't know who he is
oh I think I've seen it yeah they're
going on this like blind date and
they're like oh yeah you're really cool
you know and then that like they're just
a bunch of OJ references like they give
him a plastic knife to cut the meat with
and like was that a plastic knife a cold
kid yeah yeah there's a lot of like
there's a really dark humor stuff and
everybody hates him at the restaurant
and she's like why does everyone hate
you and it's really funny I don't want
to watch it you should watch it this I
don't want to watch it you should watch
it watch it watch it watch it I'm going
to show you guys a video clip and the
first half of it is his first video to
Twitter
that's something really weird innit
words like what would you say that he
just starts what saying I did it I'm on
Twitter
yeah and then the second half is Howard
Stern interviewing the brother of the
guy he killed or as I Kato Kaelin Julie
Ron Goldman's brother yeah
remember Kato Kaelin I said brother no
so the sister so her name is Kim
Goldman Oh wrong sister of Ronald gold
Goldman who was murdered along with
Nicole Brown back in 1994 and so he and
so let me show you that that's clip
right here he looks so happy
because he got away guilty truly now
coming soon to Twitter you'll get there
read all my thoughts and opinions of
just about everything
now there's a lot of fake oj accounts
out there so this one and the real oj 32
is the only official one so it should be
a lot of fun i got a little getting even
to be so god bless take care getting
even with who not really and not not the
words you won in chuckling about
everything i just that part is really
hard to stomach because i look at him
and think rage murderer
domestic violence abuser it's just hard
for me to see him just enjoying you know
the good life like he likes to refer to
it yeah i mean i didn't even realize i
went back and was looking in a research
and stuff and your brother was 25 years
old my name was murdered and and and she
was 35 i mean these are people who
didn't get to live their lives yeah you
think twitter should throw or jo what do
you think i say yes why do i say yes
because what would be the grounds howard
you'd have to have I don't need grounds
I own Twitter a lot of people be thrown
out yeah I just think just that just to
save you the grief of seeing him out
there by the way and use his own head
and so lay low you get away with
something like this
lay low my man well and that's the part
that I think was so confusing and then
he comes out in his first tweet as you
know I got some getting even to do and
then he talked about how he's not trying
to add I mean really that's the burning
question that's what I think you know
people wanna know yeah and about and
some manager that you're the only one
that knows this guy's name you're
worried about that I mean Philippe yeah
the thing that she was saying
that he posted another Twitter video
just setting the record straight that he
never had any sort of intimate
relationship with Kris Jenner and that
he's not Chloe's dead I didn't even know
that was a rumor
wait oh yeah that's a huge rumor oh yeah
there's a rumor that OJ's Khloe
Kardashian's dead I did not know this is
interesting cuz like I
no one likes OJ okay we all think he did
it but just to play devil's advocate
he's a free man and I think that in like
banning something off Twitter when they
haven't done anything like that the like
they should be allowed to have freedom
of speech and we should be allowed to
judge them for freedom of speech
therefore their whatever they're saying
you know if he's not on Twitter how are
we gonna talk [ __ ]
exactly it's like Donald Trump is on
Twitter and then everyone gets to talk
about everything Donald Trump tweets
like you're allowed to think that
someone's an [ __ ] and you're allowed
to think that you're allowed to heavily
disagree with everything they say but I
think like just banning people because
of you know you don't decide this that
we think that he did it even though he
didn't get proven guilty in trial which
[ __ ] sucks but it like that's you got
blood off as an innocent man and like
what can you do to that's so weird
you know what I think it is I think
Howard Stern is for freedom of speech I
think what it is the concept of deep
platforming because they're private
businesses Twitter is a corporation and
so they can decide what they do with
their platform as opposed not saying you
can't talk Oh Jay like I never want you
to talk I don't want you to be in any
public space we're in the service we
refuse the right to serve yeah what if
they don't like your Kaizen program they
don't believe in that style of fitness
and then they decide to take you off
Twitter like you want to go down without
a fight that's [ __ ]
it's a very interesting question because
the question then becomes who decides
what's wrong what's exactly whenever
there's the opportunity for tyranny so
for a Thorat aryan style ward you decide
who's right who's wrong it could get
dangerous but the counter-argument to
that and I don't think Oh Jay has
crossed that line there's that
individual called Alex Jones of Infowars
worse
some of the things that he was saying
about the Sandy Hook victims elicited a
response where some of his fans
so it's Sandy Hook you know the massacre
of the children yeah he said some of the
individuals that paired on TV I believe
a war actors yeah so some of the parents
and their children attend Iran and so
they got dogs yeah by these uber Alex
Jones fans and so if your words incite
violence or incite a certain amount
certain things to happen then I think
deep platforming can occur especially
one of what you're doing is potentially
dangerous to society how we determine
that is very very very hard to do he
walks the line because he's like I'm
gonna die got some words to say on
Twitter and he's like I'm not Chloe's
dad like he knows ways the way he could
get away with and not get away with he's
all long as he's like probably has a
lawyer that reviews opposed which so it
makes it really hard because once you
say oh this person's got banned for
saying this now everyone that says those
types of things whatever it is it's like
you have to use but just because you
don't like someone and you want to take
them off before they say something that
you don't like that I don't agree with
yes he didn't [ __ ] up yet right well I
mean eight hundred and sixty-five
thousand followers that's a lot of
60,000 other people like to hate what
yeah why they hate watch but I also
think it depends but you have verify it
I need a medicine that's on who you ask
what they believe yes here's the thing
like I watched this whole documentary on
did I it started hurting race
relationships yeah in LA yeah because
the black community they just could not
get behind the fact that he killed
anybody because he was so supportive and
and he gave back so much to the
community and he did so many great
things that for them it was like nah Oh
Jay no he's my friend I can't I can't
not during that period where it's like
Rodney King right and there was a lot of
tension with and that was their way of
saying well you know what white people
got away with so much [ __ ] anyway oh you
know let us have one that's
which to be honest I could kind of
definitely understand yeah the concept
is also I think then justices of times
passed for so many innocent of black
individuals were incarcerated so even if
in the hypothetical situation that he
committed it so many other people get
away all the time and they don't make
any yeah news or any story about it who
cares it was but it's just the way he
handles it like in a sociopath
narcissists way oh my god dry school
he's not a good represent look they're
genuinely there's a book called just
mercy that deals with a lawyer Bryan
Stevenson that deals with people that
were wrongfully convicted on death row
and then he did his life's work to get
them free those are the people words
again that's a great injustice oh
Jessica man like you just keep messing
like I don't want to back you up anymore
I did believe in you but oh [ __ ] man
you're so suspicious and you're so cocky
after yeah like you're not like oh I
feel so bad for the family let's catch
the killer that actually right he's like
I didn't do it every wrong step yeah
have you heard the theory about the CT
injury making his violent tendencies and
all these because you know how like in
football that it's been coming yeah I
could definitely see and then you do
have football players that are going to
do doing crazy criminal violent behavior
and they're like well he was actually a
good boy I don't know why he's doing
gangster [ __ ] now but that's one of the
theories of OJ going berserk from like
the the brain injuries in like juicy top
yeah there's actually a buddy of mine is
a hockey player and his growing up he
was completely normal professional
professional and he's now stuff he's one
of the bruisers so he gets in the fights
but he suffered so many concussions
throughout his career that it's changed
he has told me his perspective on things
or how he views things how even
processes it because his brain he says
doesn't function the same way he could
feel it so prior to 20 years old or just
right he has no criminal record enough
and he still doesn't but just his
tendencies and how he thinks and how his
depression and the way his brain set up
where are you guessing in some dark
places and he and he actually has
volunteered himself for some of the
research that we're talking about where
he believes he's like
I don't think this is just me and my
life stage right I've had a turn of
events and I just feel like a bad person
now or all these thoughts entering my
head like I feel that the things I've
gone to even there's ability to remember
certain things is off yeah so yeah the
more they discover about that I I think
that's probably a factor yeah I mean
obviously they might kick him out cause
he hasn't violated any of the terms of
Twitter right so it's just interesting
to see what else he ends up tweeting out
it's crazy how 800,000 people are like
you're thinking we [ __ ] hate this guy
but I'm gonna fall I still want to hear
what yesterday with I guess with Trump
you know some people but like a huge
chunk of his following I feel is like
the people I hate him because they're
just trying to see what else is he gonna
say
that's why Simon was so important for
American Idol because he kept everything
balanced to everyone's like I hate
watching this [ __ ] you've heard it here
first
Oh Jay Simpson 2024 presidential run oh
gosh you're calling this put it this way
Joe I've seen crazier things so I don't
think I don't think he could turn around
his entire campaign and public
perception by 2020 I mean he's has
enough by 2024 damn he might be dead by
then I secretly yeah he's like 65 very
big narcissist so I would I think he's
gonna win I said he would run we would
love 24 exactly I just missed the the
rent is too damn high guy whatever he's
at please come back
[Music]